15 pounds on a new credit card dragging
your heels a bit but not bad the rest of
you keep focused if we can't save
written money now no one can
Super Save with money supermarket
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensor from
tearing down statues to renaming
buildings and handing back Royal honors
in shame it's British history simply too
toxic they're already becoming a bunch
of History snowflakes will debate
and who takes detained in Romania again
facing allegations of human trafficking
are talking exclusively to the lawyer
now defending the world's most infamous
Infamous influencer thus boxer Tommy
Fury stepbrother of the great Tyson Jew
is about to fight one of the biggest
YouTube stars on the planet tens of
millions will watch but is it a stunt
that undermines the Integrity of a sport
or a real fight I'll ask him Tommy Fury
live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening London welcome
to Piers Morgan on Center the British
empire built roads schools and hospitals
across much of the world It ultimately
also abolished slavery but the Empire
also committed some horrific atrocities
in its Conquest just as American history
is cloudy by being built on the backs of
the wicked slave trade but illuminated
by defeat of the Nazis and communism
history is complicated the past is
riddled with terrible and heinous acts
committed less enlightened times that is
a fact but it's also a fact that none of
these things are your fault they're not
my fault either we weren't there just as
this Preposterous in my view to blame
King Charles for the toxic masculinity
of Henry VII which some people are doing
it's unhinged to imagine that today's
generation can or should bear
responsibility for their ancestors isn't
it the self-flagellation is the Vogue
there's viral currency and apologizing
for everything in our past to vaunt our
virtue today well that's what the actor
Alan [__] has done by handing back
his Obe and a flurry of indignant rage
it was given to him by the late Queen in
2009 he blamed the toxicity of Empire
adding he'd been grateful at the time
but now his eyes are opened really Alan
they were shot were they for all those
decades that you were alive as a
supposedly intelligent man you had no
idea about the British Empire
it's not really true is it Alan just the
Queen's now no longer here so you feel
emboldened to go on a little PR Rampage
about how disgusted you are by the whole
thing he doesn't quite realize it Mr
cutting but really that's the point of
this it seemed fine at the time but
Fashions are sensibilities have changed
and by today's standards it all seems
terrible but history itself of course
stays the same sustained assault in the
past isn't just irritating has direct
consequences the royal family now has
repeatedly hounded by demand for
apologies whether they Tour the World
the Ferocious debate about reparations
the descendants of slavery in the U.S is
toxic and divisive it makes ordinary
people who have nothing at all to do
with slavery and detest the whole notion
of it feel like they're under attack for
something that had nothing to do with it
reduces us to oppressors and the
oppressed instead of Simply people who
mostly want to make the world a better
place tearing down statues renaming
buildings endlessly apologizing for our
ancestors might make some sensitive
people feel better about themselves and
get them a few likes on social media but
does it make the world a better place
well joining me now are author and
playwright Bonnie Greer Obe
an academic Professor Nigel bigger CBE
Professor biggest book on colonism was
canceled by the publisher for concluding
the British Empire was not all bad plus
the commentator and best-selling author
Douglas Murray as yet shamefully
unhonored and we intend to correct that
by the end of this program I've done
this so get you something out of this at
the very least
um all right let's start Bonnie you have
an honor which you accepted it's the
order of the British Empire what did you
think you were getting you're going to
pull an allen count I think I think I
had no idea I think it's the office
officer of the British Empire you're
commander of the British Empire I
thought it was ordering is that no
officer the Europe officer and and
Nigel's Commander well how does your
role as officer of the British Empire
square with your criticism of the
British Empire well for one thing
um I took the honor uh peers on behalf
of my late father he was here for D-Day
he was in a segregated Army the British
people were wonderful to him he loved
this country of the people and I took it
on his behalf because no one gave him a
medal at all and I told the Nile King
Charles exactly why I did it and he said
Thank you so I love that story so when
my when uh at my mother's funeral I
pinned the medal on her dress so it's
it's for my dad meant a lot to you it
meant a lot for me because of my
father's so when you see Alan [__]
and that's a it's a great story by the
way and it's wonderful to hear that
because all you hear at the moment is
all the negative stuff from the British
past that's a nice story it's a positive
story but when you hear Adam coming in
this fit of rage hurling back his honor
and saying he's just woken up to the
reality of the horrors of the British
Empire what is your response there well
I was giggling a little bit when you did
your uh opening oratorio because
actually he would have known this
especially being a Scott about
I mean that's a natural thing
um you know no Empire and I don't know
what you've written Nigel but no Empire
by definition is a good thing because
what it actually is a about is about
someone has to be oppressed to be
history in my opinion here's where I
come at all these things yeah history is
nuanced right yes current history will
be nuanced yes uh what we went through
50 years ago 100 years ago a thousand
years ago everything is nuanced in the
sense there's good and bad in all these
uh exactly exactly but then we go back
to and I'm just thinking automatically
of uh the the first strike of Indian
independence which is called the Indian
Mutiny I think they would disagree with
the idea of Empire they would disagree
with the Empire so was nothing coming
wrong to hand back his honor uh he was
right because he wanted to do it but the
reason he did it I don't really I mean
if he didn't know that I don't know I
don't know to those who say well Bonnie
you know you're if you're if you're that
concerned about the British Empire how
do you feel comfortable having a title
given to you by the royal family on
behalf of the monarchy which of course
was a major part of the British Empire
how do you feel feel about keeping that
honor as an officer of the British
Empire if you feel that way about what
the empire did I as I said I did it for
my dad I understand
and hang on and I get that but what
about you person your view I never say
Obe people call me that they'll put it
behind my name I never ever say anything
about the Obe but I won't relinquish it
and it's because of my father okay uh
Nigel you wrote a book Professor to give
your proper title but you wrote a book
about uh colonialism a moral Reckoning
it was canceled by Bloomsbury we live in
this absurd world now where Publishers
are censoring authors after they
commissioned books and tell them what
are you going to write about and they
say this and they say great and then you
write about it and then they cancel you
yeah which apart from anything else is
ridiculous so I just think Publishers
are making themselves a concern but what
was the pretext of your book and what is
the overview that you drew in conclusion
about the British Empire the British
Empire I mean you mentioned uh slavery
um and and that's true for 150 years the
British were involved in slaving other
people Africans like everyone else in
the world I mean even in in I was in
North Carolina
um earlier this month and went to the
museum with history of North Carolina
which told me that in 1860 on the eve of
the American Civil War 30
000 emancipated slaves some of whom kept
slaves themselves right which is so
common but in the early 1800s was among
the first states in the history of the
world the history of the world to
abolish the slave trade and the leader
in suppressing the slave trade all over
the world from from Brazil to Malaysia
may I just ask you a question I'm sorry
to interrupted and I would ask you this
because you know more about this than me
would I understand is that the abolition
of the slave trade was partly a reason a
way for the Royal Navy to have Supremacy
on the seas in fact the world Navy
boarded slave ships and and this was
more about the Royal Navy than it was
about abolitionists yeah you're kind of
saying that the Royal Navy wanted to
exert itself and so freeing slave is one
way to do it that's kind of back to
front I mean the Royal Navy spent in the
mid in 1830s it's been about 13 of the
total Manpower just Manning uh um ships
on the coast of West Africa to stop
slavers and 17 000 Sailors died of
disease
why was your book
canceled by your publisher why didn't
they publish uh uh um a reliable source
tells me that that woke Junior Employers
in in Bloomsbury publishing protested
against publishing anything they didn't
agree with and for some reason I don't
understand the grown-ups in Senior
Management uh caved in but that is the
problem isn't it in this culture is that
you've got these very young woke
employees who buy into all these
narratives and then they think it's
completely right to work for a publisher
supposedly supporting free speech in a
Democratic Society like the like Britain
and they think it's fine to actually try
and get that author cancel because they
don't agree with some of the stuff
you've written here's can I say
something too I mean woke I'm I'm so
unhappy about that name being taken over
because we're going to talk about
history woke was a a signal to us in
we're talking about slavery to people
escaping from slavery they use the word
on the Underground Railroad that was one
of the signals well it was mainly
actually
actually began mainly in the 60s in the
black music community in America and it
was established as a way of expressing a
bigger awareness of Social and racial
Injustice I completely sign up to that
by that definition I'm woke what woke
has and what's happened to the word it's
been hijacked by people who are now
behaving like right and behavior
who's a professor because you know that
because you know that you shouldn't use
it the way you use it well because you
know that okay
your historical Point's World taken but
in this context woke refers to it
simple movement yes we're using the
story all right okay I want to bring in
douglasma you could go that way but
since it's being used as a badge of
honors well you shouldn't do it I think
it's become literally a badge of the new
fascism it's basically people now
embrace the word wokes themselves say
I'm so so woke that if you say anything
I don't like I'm going to ruin shame
villified kids you have the power to
instruct people about where the word oh
I've came I've wrote a whole book about
it then then you shouldn't you shouldn't
use it that way I wrote a book
literally I wrote a book the number one
you shouldn't use still available
I want to bring in Douglas Murray he's
been waiting very patiently Douglas
where are we with this where every
single aspect of our history I'm sitting
here with an eminent Professor whose
book about Colonial Britain was was
banned by its own Publishers because
woke employees rattled their little
oversensitive snowflakey cages at him
right but what does it say about society
that this is happening what does it say
about history of this country of America
that almost everything in history now we
have to feel ashamed about
unfortunately it says that there's one
prevailing narrative and you're not
meant to say anything against it whether
the prevailing narrative is true or not
and on this occasion the prevailing
narrative is not true the prevailing
narrative at the moment in Britain is a
sort of import from the American culture
wars where we've uh tried to put the
legacy of slavery in America over the
legacy of colonialism in Britain make it
our founding original sin and derive all
of our morality and our scolding of the
past
from that I mean we've seen uh Sir
Francis Drake as the latest victim of
this or an Explorer from the 1500s gets
a run through our 2020s Paradigm and
found to be failing
um it's happened with absolutely
everyone Lord Nelson to Winston
Churchill and I I think this this
Paradigm is wildly unfit for purpose and
the problem is is that when anyone goes
against it as Professor Nigel bigger has
we see the consequences and the problem
problem is this appears but what we're
suffering from is this massive ignorance
in our society we're very ignorant
people have been grabbing the microphone
and saying there's only one way to look
at the past and that's with us being the
very enlightened clever brilliant modern
people and everyone in the past being
guilty of sin and the fact is if you say
look we need more Nuance on that you get
the backlash I mean Nigel bigger knows
this because when he tried to some years
ago docs would start a course in the
ethics of Empire that was lambasted by
academics you know if if academics at
Oxford including the then Regis
professor of Ethics are not allowed to
look at the ethics of Empire the things
that were good in it the things that
were bad in it what the moral Reckoning
should be who is meant well the worst
one is it the worst one for me William
Douglas there was a guy you you'll know
this story there was a professor at a
university in America I can't remember
which one it was now but he of the 25
years had delivered a brilliant lecture
about the use of offensive language and
as part of the lecture he would use a
offensive language to illustrate what he
was talking about and he got canceled
because the students protested about him
using offensive language in a lecture he
delivered for a quarter of a century
yeah about the offensive thing is look
they're about five different artists
the thing with that one is peers in a
way that that one is a slam dunk because
it's just like it's it's ridiculous in a
course about language to sort of end up
policing language like that but the
point about history it can't be stressed
enough there is a very malevolent malign
interpretation of our history in Britain
that is going on at the moment and it
needs historians and others to correct
it it's not about a one you know
dogmatic narrative for placing another
quite the opposite it's saying there is
a dogmatic and untrue narrative being
pushed on British history it's time to
add some context and the fact there are
Publishers and universities and others
in Britain that say we don't want that
context we want to ban that context says
something so unhealthy is going I'm just
currently Douglas your response to Alan
[__] returning his his Obe over
misgiving and surrounding the toxicity
of the British Empire which he
apparently suddenly realized he woke up
after the queen died and realized there
may have been some issues with the
British Empire which he had had an OB
from for many years
you know you know Alan Cummings I have
infinite disdain for I mean he's a he's
a nasty little Scottish nationalist who
lives in California and talks about how
Scotland should be independent if he
wanted to jump on the anti-imperial
bandwagon he should have done it 20
years ago because Benjamin Zephaniah and
others did this a long time ago and
refusing this honor so I mean I can sort
of believe that Alan Cummings hadn't
heard of the British Empire until this
year I sort of can believe it because he
he runs so many contradictory narratives
in his head yeah I completely agree
Bonnie you've been raging away here
let's talk about contradictory
narratives I mean first of all
um we all have an obligation
particularly an historian and a
particular man who's written a book on
the subject to separate out how the word
came into being and how it is used now
it's very important it's very important
I did all that okay no no you need to
read my book no well well we do well
he's like he's going to uh
a group of monkeys at my Publishing
Company also
can I finish okay that's the first thing
about woke it's very important it's very
important to me that you get that right
where that came from you need to
remember I don't need to read your books
about it well I lived it okay I'm from
Chicago I know it was about I don't need
to read your book well you just said I
need to do more about it no I don't no I
don't I need to do something but when I
tell you I've already done you see no
you that's your that's your point of
view
apart from I hope this has this book
been published anyway oh it's coming out
tomorrow brilliant yep
William Collins fantastic brave people
well get out there and buy it and don't
denigrate the word woke because it comes
from a very special sacred place you
don't do it clean it up I don't need to
read your books I don't need to read
your book I don't need to read I'm going
to send you my books
I don't need to read it 300 000 people
have bought it I'm gonna give you I'll
even sign a copy for you I'm gonna read
one for you welcome your book I want to
show this to the camera because this was
the one they tried to ban it's coming
out uh tomorrow it's called colonianism
a moral Reckoning of Professor Nigel
bigger it's a fantastic book should
never have been canceled I wish you all
the best with it thank you with a flying
bestseller you need to read my phone no
no you need to listen to me
good to see you Bonnie good to see you
uh we're coming next I wanted just to
make a little announcement
um when Boris Johnson was prime minister
he kept promising me that he would do a
big sit-down interview with me in down
history and he kept monaging on that
promise culminating in a farcical team
when he ran into a fridge on live
television and stayed in there to avoid
talking to me so a few months ago I met
Richie sunak at an event I asked him can
I have an interview with you uh now that
you're prime minister because I do it
down the street yes getting the answer
and I got a call yesterday to say come
tomorrow so tomorrow morning I'll be
with the Prime Minister Rishi Suna it'll
be the first time I've ever interviewed
a conservative prime minister at Downing
Street looking forward to it done a few
labor Prime Ministers there but never a
conservative one and he says a lot about
Richie soon though but he hasn't run
into a fridge to hide from the
questioning I'll be giving him and is to
mark 100 days in office for Richard or
as we now call him a trade to Liz
trusses uh so it'll be me uh tomorrow
night uh the whole show P.M and the p.m
see what I did there uh coming up next
more rabid shouting no we're gonna have
another no another big debate see in a
moment
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
I have a flurry of texts there from
people who've had honors and I'm very
proud of them thank you very much and
don't think very much of Alan [__]
for accepting it and then sending it
back in a little virtue signaling Peak
but first on his 100th day in office
tomorrow I'll be sitting down with prime
minister Rishi sunak a number 10 Downing
Street for an inclusive interview uh
that's tomorrow morning to air tomorrow
night but joining the studio now to
debate this in advance and mirrors
Associated to Kevin McGuire taught to be
contributor Esther Krakow plus from
Westminster talk to the Philippians of
Clinton can and from New York former
conservative MP Louise menso a veritable
Feast of a panel tonight welcome to all
of you let's start with Kate McCann down
in in Westminster what is the general
view about how Rishi sunac has done in
his first hundred days particularly in
context of the fact he's already
outlasted two Liz trusses
I think it depends very much who you ask
peers and that's because it's very easy
to forget how much chaos there was here
in Westminster just a couple of months
ago getting rid of prime ministers on a
whim some people suggested conservative
MPS plotting in corridors Michigan came
in with a promise to essentially make
politics a little bit boring again and I
think most of his party thinks that he's
done that but of course once you look
past that that's where the problems
start because people in his party want
policies they want things to change and
the reality is that he's come in
dragging a whole load of baggage that
the party had accumulated over the last
couple of months that he can't really do
anything about and you're seeing that
play out now with those you know
political scandals who's had to get rid
of his own chairman didn't want to do
that had to do it in the end he's now
got an investigation into Dominic rub
and lots of Whispers going on tonight in
the bars behind me in Parliament about
potentially Dominic Rob quitting before
that investigation is over now those
close to him say that's not going to
happen but the Prime Minister doesn't
want to focus on this he wants to talk
about policy and when you look across
that well he's got no money he's the
former Chancellor he knows exactly how
much cash is in the public person the
answer is not very much there are many
here in Parliament who question his
approach to particularly the nurses
strike and nurses pay and I think for
Tory MPS who are looking back some of
them will remember that chaos and think
well thank God we're not there anymore
but others who have quite short memories
will think well this guy was supposed to
be the next big thing and we don't
necessarily think he's made a huge
impact yet there is mixed opinion I
think it's better okay uh Kevin McGuire
I mean look on the on the positive note
he hasn't tanked the pound he hasn't
tanked the economy and he hasn't gone
completely start roving mad so he's a
distinct Improvement on his immediate
predecessor
um but you know he's 100 days in he's
only got about 500 Days maximum until a
general election
very hard to actually get anything
significantly done particularly with an
ongoing very Grim economy no he's coming
out what really feels like the [__] end
of conservative Rule and can he turn it
around can he save him a lot of his own
MPS don't respect him I mean that is the
problem you know you go drinking with
them have coffees with them chat them
follow it all the time
I think it's because they think he just
hasn't got a touch for politics you look
he didn't think there was a problem his
wife and heirs fabulously wealthy was a
non-dom avoiding tax in the UK he didn't
think it was wrong for him to keep a U.S
green Card so he could scarp her over
there if it didn't work out here and
work back in America even the stupidity
of recording himself uh get making a
statement without a seat belt on so he
gets none of those things to me were
massive they add up they added up but
they're just a rough and tumble of
normal people you painted Gavin
Williamson as a cabinet minister he had
a uh I certainly wouldn't have done that
and I wouldn't have bought Sue Ellen
bravaman back so quickly after six years
I thought the way that he dealt with
Nadeem zahawi Esther you know it was the
way I think leaders should do it which
is you you start an inquiry it doesn't
go on very long you get to the facts and
you take action to be honest I think he
is kind of just studying the ship as
best as he possibly can I think your
point that you know his conservative MPS
are really respective it's quite
poignant because he's a technocrat he's
not a politician you can see even the
way he interacts with the media for
instance when he was asked if he has a
private GP yeah he should have said yes
I have a private GP because I can afford
it it's my moral duty to take burden off
the NHS by by you know affording my own
paying for my own health care but he
didn't he ran away from the question
which was mind-boggling because you know
that was a clear opportunity for him to
score a very easy win so he doesn't have
a very good sort of media manner he's
not as charismatic but he's not about to
me he's not a bad phone like Boris Jones
oh absolutely right and he's not a
persistent liar like Boris Johnson from
what I've seen so far he looks the part
he sounds the part you know he looks he
looks like he takes the job seriously
that is a step up on the last I don't
feel embarrassed when he goes abroad
right right which I did with Johnson
trust wasn't really an opportunity to do
it but at the same time has he got the
ideas where are his big ideas
oh come on you can see labor would
transform with the taxes
they would have negotiated you would
have these strikes let me bring in
another aspect to this which is the
aforementioned Boris Johnson is clearly
On Maneuvers I mean quite literally
he's popped up in Ukraine glad handing
president zielinski he's been to
Congress in America glad handing Mitch
McConnell and other Senate leaders and
so on
um what's he up to well Louise mens
you're a Boris fan what is he up to
because he's pretending like he's the
foreign secretary stroke de facto I
should still be prime minister isn't he
absolutely he is and you're totally
right that he's on maneuvers he wants to
be The Once and Future King and I looked
up the actual polls before I came on
tonight in June of last year before
Boris Johnson was pushed out the deficit
the Tories had to labor was seven
percent after a hundred days of Rishi
sunak it's now 22 points or 22 points
down in the polls to labor that's really
not sustainable if you want not only to
to win the next election seems like a
distant a distant goal but even to limit
your losses and I think Boris is waiting
for the results of the local elections
in May he's waiting to see if he can say
to the party this guy is going to lose
every single seat we have it was all a
mistake let's just wipe it out and go
back what I was saying okay for what I
was saying what I would say is you've
conveniently neglected to mention the
real culprit I suspect in all this which
was Liz truss who's unbelievably
terrible reign of 44 days of Financial
Terror spooked the entire Global markets
tanked a pound to record lows so on and
so on and so on fortunately she went
before but let's just even expired and
that was that but the damage had to be
repaired and the pound is now back from
a a low of like 102 to 123 now in in
terms of the pound dollar rate you know
if you if you're trying to be positive
about Rishi Sunnah you'd say well at
least he stabilized stuff like that I
mean that's an advantage of where we
were back in September
yeah and he took the tours from
something crazy like a 40-point deficit
down to a 20-point deficit but he hasn't
done any better than that and frankly
Piers I can do better than a head of
lettuce isn't much of a recommendation
for a prime minister it's really not
what is the point of Rishi sunak what is
sunakism there is no such thing as I'm
going to ask him
questions what is I'm gonna there you go
see great minds I actually think it's
interesting to ask you I'm going to ask
him look you've been in power for a
hundred days it doesn't sound a lot but
it's a lot more than your breeder says
um and actually the big question now is
what do you stand for and what do you
want your country to be and how are you
going to get us there because he hasn't
got that long you know he's only got a
maximum of 500 Days to call the election
so this is in politics that will whiz by
the economy obviously is continuing to
be massively problematic I just wonder
about Boris Johnson's loyalty here does
it exist Does he have a loyal bone in
his body or is it is every waking
basically
he just wants to be prime minister he
was in my opinion a better prime
minister even with all the scandals
he had a vision well that's not what the
opinion polls say appears you can't get
away from it under Boris seven points
down to labor at the worst under Rishi
22 points down it's simple you're
missing his trust again missing the one
in the middle it's like saying him as a
triangle with two points
I just don't think the country should
even think about going back to Boris
Johnson it's a complete the idea of
going from somebody who looks and sounds
like they've got a brain and have a
sense of Duty about them going back to
this buffoon is careering around the
world for purely self-interest I think
he's ridiculous I think we need to
remember the fact that Boris took a
spectacular win in 2019 a massive sort
of and ruined it it's incredible that in
what three years that's that's a record
today he read today he told someone an
interview in America Kevin he said you
know anyone who thinks I need you about
these illicit parties or in any way with
countenance and going on you know really
it has lost their mind which I tweeted
I've lost my mind yeah because clearly
of course he did of course of course he
is having this building he was in his
home he was cracking jokes about the
lack of social distancing at some of
them no like he's he's stalking sunac I
mean soon I should get a restraining
order because she'll soon that'd be done
and I might ask him but should he be
doing more to keep Boris Johnson under
under control because at the moment
I don't know what a prime minister can
do but probably still used to have quite
good power to do that to an MP but he's
an MP yeah but you're dealing with a
giant ego who just puts himself first
second and third and all it is I've
known him for 30 odd years did you give
him too much attention then the
attention literally shifts onto Boris
and it's like well the country has
bigger issues than this buffoon I think
you just let him do what he wants to do
he needs to accept the fact that he's
never coming back as prime minister but
Rishi sunak has much bigger fish to fry
and labor love it though they they are
people like Louise mention there's a
little johnsonite just ignoring the
reality and pushing him forward all the
time fantastic let's go to little Louise
bench for a final word on that I mean
Louise there you are yeah they're
maneuvering with Boris Boris Johnson is
a yeah but Boris Johnson is a winner
he's won an election Rishi sunak wasn't
only not not put in by the people of the
of Britain he wasn't even put in by the
members of the Tory party and if your
panel think that the conservative party
is going to go gentle into that good
night and take the 20-point drop with
Rishi they've got another thing coming
brilliant you know who was put in by the
by the members of the conservative party
Liz truss yep it just about says
everything to me about their judgment
anyway
um Louise mentioned good to see
obviously seeing you in New York shortly
a couple of weeks thank you very much
you're staying with me to the pack Kate
McCann oh one question for UK before we
go actually
uh they're all groaning in my eggs I
want to move on to the break so that's
going to make me even more determined to
talk to you a little further Kate
um this idea of Boris Johnson returning
politically is it even a starter are
people beginning to get a little bit
jittery about this
peers I think Westminster Watchers will
be thinking tonight that actually if
anyone's due for a comeback or thinks
that they could be it's Liz trust not
Boris Johnson I think it's worth
watching out in the next couple of days
what you see from the former prime
minister because yes she may well have
been likened to a lettuce as Louise
Mentor is saying there but she is very
far from feeling that her career here in
politics is over so I think very much
watch this space from her from Boris
Johnson I think he's having too much fun
he gets to do what he likes say what he
likes and it still makes huge ripples
back home well you know what his own
supporters are calling him right now
Nadine Doris will be uh in the studio
tomorrow night on Friday night has got
an interview with Boris Johnson after
years of unrestrained sucking up and uh
he finally sat here with her and this
was the clip which I think says it all
listen to this
but that point just isn't the case
because Rishi is like some kind of
Submarine prime minister he isn't out at
the front making the case you're making
the case here now but you know he's not
out there
he's invisible I did I look he's been on
he's been on TV a lot more than me
lately I can tell you that much for free
oh God I can't wait to come back
uh anyway there we are the submarine
prime minister is what Boris Johnson's
allies are calling Rishi sooner I'll put
that to the Prime Minister tomorrow
whether he views himself as a submarine
prime minister or maybe it's time to put
his Periscope up and gun down Boris
Johnson on his Maneuvers uh coming up
next as his appeal against attention
fails and replays lawyer talks
exclusively uncensored don't go away
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
my next Andrew Tate will spend the next
month Behind Bars of Romania to losing
the latest appeal against his detention
taking his brother Tristan are being
held as part of a investigation into
rape and human trafficking or speaking
outside Court Andrew takes it he's done
nothing wrong
no I'm innocent
there's no much Justice
[Music]
well the pack is still with me plus
joining me now is the lawyer full of
Tate Brothers Tina glandian who is in
Romania well welcome to uh Miss Danny I
really appreciate you joining me where
are we with this case it seems like
every now and again this pops up back on
television with them being reminded for
further time how long can that process
continue before a charging decision is
made
under Romanian law they have up to 180
days which is in 30-day increments so
every time there's a 30-day detention
order they're allowed to renew their
request and have it extended for an
additional 30 days but not to exceed 180
days okay
you've taken on this case Andrew Tate
has been repeatedly uh bellowing his
innocence as he's been LED in and out of
of these uh Court hearings and so on
do you believe them do you believe that
he and his brother are innocent
at this point Pierce they've had this
investigation going since April we're
now February and there are not even
charges filed against them so this is a
huge Injustice the way we see it they
should not be detained at this point we
think it's now crossed over to the point
where it's violating international human
rights law because the deprivation of of
your Liberty pre-trial is the most
severe form of punishment a state can
impose and that's what they've done in
this case and they've had a very lengthy
investigation with the government's
resources they've been analyzing and
looked looking at all of their devices
since April When They seized everything
and here we are February and charges
aren't filed so I think there's
absolutely no evidence that's been
presented
and that's our position what is I mean
how are your clients at the moment how
is Andrew Tate dealing with
incarceration I mean I interviewed him
just before Christmas we had a long
wide-ranging interview and once again I
was struck by the phenomenal
following that he has online
particularly with young men you know he
has an enormous following there
you and I know this has been whipped up
now by that Community into a huge
framing of a narrative this is complete
Injustice there are others who think
this has been a long time coming that
he's a bad human being and that he's
going to face very serious charges and
that will be the last we see of him
um but how is he faring right now given
that at the moment he's in this limbo
land of no charging but being held uh in
incarceration
the brothers are both very strong
they're resilient and they're holding up
but obviously the conditions are not
good they're in a Romanian jail cell and
they've been detained for a very lengthy
period at this point they have limited
access to their attorneys um it's it's
not a good condition for them
you've obviously as far as sorry please
finish
I was just gonna I was gonna say to your
second point
their controversial public figures but
that's not a crime and at this point we
have not been provided any proof that
they've committed any crimes nor have
they even been charged so I would ask
that people presume them innocent as
they are
do they feel that they are being tried
in the court of public opinion
I think I think
I think is divided as you know I think
they have a big following but at the end
of the day yes I think there is a lot of
information in the public I think
there's a lot of false allegations in
the public
I think some evidence has now been put
forth again I don't want to comment too
much on the facts of the case since
there is an ongoing criminal
investigation however I think there has
been evidence put out
um videos and other statements for the
public to see what the uh supposed state
of the evidence actually is
it's been interesting to watch Andrew
Tate's Twitter feed in particular that
he's continued to tweet is he doing that
himself has he got people doing that for
him and how do you feel from a legal
point of view is it is it a wise tactic
to continue to do that on social media
when you're being held in custody by the
remaining authorities
well again he doesn't have access so
he's not doing anything directly and
what's being put out is is on his
accounts and
I'm not going to speak as to you know
the source of of the posts and what's
being put out but I think again as of
now he's not charged with anything and
he's free to comment
publicly if you wishes to yeah they've
obviously we know that They seized uh
nearly three and a half million pounds
in cash 11 luxury sports cars guns and
other weapons or any of the things that
have been seized from the property are
they in themselves acts of law breaking
just the possession of any of these
things
to my knowledge they're not I think if
they were they would have been charged
with crimes again they they had the
initial search in April and it's
February it's been 10 months and no
charges have been filed whatsoever
we have an ongoing criminal
investigation for which this is a
preventative detention which is why
they're in custody again this is the
most severe form of punishment I don't
think it's Justified under these
circumstances where the prosecution
hasn't set forth enough evidence to
charge them and yet they are detained
and it's being prolonged
but you do accept of course that if the
women who've come forward here is part
of the investigation if they're telling
the truth these are very serious
allegations against your clients which
could lead to charging and if a led to
charging could lead potentially to Long
prison centers if found guilty
certainly the the crimes that issue are
very serious crimes and I think Pierce
actually it was on your show when you
interviewed Tate several months ago he
made very strong statements about his
position on rape and he condemned rape
and he said it was disgusting was I'm
pretty sure the word he used and he said
he thought that somebody who does that
deserves the death penalty so there's no
question that these are serious charges
and even in his own words they're very
serious charges there just isn't any
evidence that they committed these
crimes but you know we've also had tapes
which have emerged in the last few weeks
of him talking about rape to a woman in
a pretty unsavory manner so what is your
response to that
can you I'm sorry I didn't catch that
you said what surfaced did there have
been various tapes of surfaced in part
of media investigations in the last few
weeks including Andrew Tate talking
about rape to a woman in a pretty
unsavory manner so what would your
reaction be to that
first of all I think the authenticity of
anything that is presented through the
media as opposed to turned over to the
defense needs to be questioned because
material is edited and it's it's easily
manipulated so first I would say that
secondly I don't think certain text
messages
um you know there are I'm not here to
judge or to talk to people's desires or
fetishes but certainly somebody could
easily set someone up by saying they
like they have certain fantasies they
want
certain things done to them or said to
them and so there's a lot that goes into
you can't take a text message out of
context you first have to know uh first
of all the entire context of it and what
the background is there needs to be
explanation so I think you have to keep
all of that in mind when you're seeing
something in the media we do and we have
to give your mind also the judge's
reasoning for all this I explained on
the 20th of January that they viewed the
particular dangerousness of the
defendants and their capacity to
identify victims with increased
vulnerability in search of better life
opportunities so all of this has to be
taken into account but it goes on and as
you rightly say at the moment there have
been no charges against your clients and
until or if that point arrives we're in
a world of allegation not actual charges
correct and right now exactly there's a
presumption of innocence
to and that every accused has and that
attaches from the time you're even
charged and here we're not even there
they haven't even charged them with
crimes so any sort of comments as to the
their alleged dangerousness there's no
there's no evidence of that there isn't
even a presumption of that they need to
be presumed innocent and that's that
hasn't happened in this case there's
really a lack of evidence and they are
being detained unlawfully at this point
I appreciate you joining me thank you
very much indeed
thank you pierce
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Fury will fight Jake Paul and Saudi
Arabia this month one is a boxer the
other is a YouTuber so what's it all
about
let's have a look
Tommy loses he can stay in Saudi Arabia
Saudi Arabia he can become Cristiano
Ronaldo's best panel and he become a PT
for Ronaldo in Saudi
well Tommy Fury joins me now you're
going to become the Cristiano Ronaldo of
boxing in Saudi apparently no bad thing
to be my mate in Saudi the highest paid
athlete in the world at 37.
yeah definitely I mean uh there's a
reason he's gone outside isn't he but uh
best thoughts Cristiano Ronaldo in there
in his move out there hope he plays even
better football out there now look
there's a very interesting debate about
these YouTubers turn boxes about whether
they're making a mockery of the greats
Board of boxing you're a boxer and
always have been but what do you make of
it I mean are they at a level now these
Paul brothers were actually that
argument no longer carries water
I mean at the end of the day um in my
opinion
it's bringing new eyes to boxing and
that's the only positive thing I can say
about it really
um other than that it is what it is you
they're not proper professional boxers
you know they're just people who's
playing at it you know doing it to
entertain the crowd earn a few quids and
that's it really but when you put one of
those in with a professional boxer well
you're all about to see what's going to
happen but I don't know it's bringing
new eyes to the sport you know kids are
getting involved that wouldn't normally
watch it so yeah it's great what if you
lose I mean Tyson's already made it
clear what his reaction will be which is
basically disowning you by the sound of
it but for you to to lose to someone
who's not even a real boxer that would
be Unthinkable right
of course and that's why that's not an
option there is no way that this man
could beat me even if you had a hammer
in both hands I gotta say that way and
I'm going to exhibit that yeah I've made
it two rules in life never fight anyone
called Tyson or Fury
just seems to me to be a active cell
phone
well soon it's going to be never fight
anyone called Tyson and never fight
anyone called Tommy because I'm going to
prove that and turn off the under four
weeks out of interest if you had a fight
ever had a fight with uh with Tyson
I've had many fights with Tyson in the
gym yes but I can't reach his head so
I'll just take his hips that's where I'm
online with have you ever knocked each
other out
uh no I mean at the end of the day if I
steal his breakfast he might eat with a
few good right hands and wobble me up a
bit but that's not happened so far I'm a
bit more wiser than that no more
personally last time I interviewed uh
Tyson he was on this show and I he said
he was retiring and I said I don't
believe you and in fact if you do come
back in the ring professionally you've
got to give me a million pounds will you
take the BET and he took it live on air
and then said on talksport he would pay
me in pound coins can you just tell him
I'm still waiting and every morning I
run down to the the post office there's
no bag of coins Tommy
well I'm sorry Pierce but I hate to say
I haven't got the stones to go up to and
ask for your million pound you have to
do that yourself
I'll ring I'm not scared I'll ring him
um what's going to happen in this fight
you think you're gonna knock him out
I know I'm going to knock him out this
fight will not go any more than four
rounds and the stuff that I'm doing in
the gym the people that I'm handling in
the gym there's no way this goes the
distance
and he apparently uh went on social
media to reveal that you'd become a
father without you guys even getting the
chance you and Molly may your partner to
say it yourself
listen at the end of the day all Jake
Paul can do from you know wherever he is
in this world is speculate and that's
all that was speculation and you know
nothing's ever true unless you hear it
from me and Molly
do you like the trash talking side of
boxing
it's part of the parcel you know it is
what it is it's stuff that we have to do
it's um it's called you know the
entertainment business that's the game
that we're in and me and me and Jake
Paul are great dance Partners
um and I've enjoyed the build up so far
it's going to get a lot more heated and
I can't wait but the real work starts
when we get inside them ropes and social
media can't save Jake Paul his mouth
can't save him it comes down to fighting
and I'm a lot better at doing that than
him
and just in case things don't go right
do you want me to text Cristiano tonight
and just see if he's got any spare rooms
I mean if he's uh yeah I mean why not
Saudi I mean I could come accustomed to
living out there but peers you're gonna
see pigs flying there before someone
goes wrong with me and Jake Paul I'll
tell you that well I admire you for
coming on Piers Morgan uncensored as I
did with Tyson always will always have a
fury on here you can tell Mr Paul uh
that we're looking forward to seeing him
coming on as well see how he gets on
for sure listen make him make all the
best of it Mr Jay parks in four weeks
she boxing career is completely over
because it never started in the first
place well go get him shall we go do it
for British I mean knock him out uh good
to talk to you tomorrow night the Prime
Minister uncensored p.m with the PM
that will be a show tomorrow night 8 P.M
Keep It Uncensored good night thank you
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]